in this video you're going to learn how
to solve linear equations in one
variable and we're going to talk about
the different types like a one-step
equations two-step equations variables
on both sides multi-step equations and
we're going to go through 12 examples
together there's a worksheet I have a
link in the description below it's free
you can download that and try these
problems on your own if you want to
practice or practice along with me let's
dive into the video so when you're
solving these equations I like to think
of it as
three steps three easy steps and here's
the steps that I go through in my mind I
think about simplifying the left and the
right sides of the equation first then I
try to get the variables and numbers on
opposite sides of the equal sign and
then lastly you always want to solve for
just one of the variables so One X or
one y or one Z so let's take a look at
this first example you can think of the
equal sign kind of like a dividing y
some people refer to this as the wall of
math I've heard that said and I thought
that was kind of funny basically you're
separating the left side of the equation
and the right side
but if you go through these three steps
and these will be more important as we
get into the multi-step equations you
know where there's more than one step
but let's just walk through it so if you
simplify the left side you say hmm is
there anything that I can do to like
combine these together or condense this
well not really because this is a
variable and this is a number and
they're unlike terms
when we go to the right side is there
anything we can simplify here no that's
just a number 7.1 so then I would go to
step number two I'd say well I want to
get the variables and the numbers on
opposite sides so right now I can see
that this variable or this unknown
quantity X is on the left
so what I want to do is I want to get
the numbers on the right side now the
way that you do that is you do the
opposite so adding and subtracting your
opposites multiplying and dividing our
opposites and so in this case since
we're adding 2.5 let's do the opposite
let's subtract 2.5 from both sides it's
really like a kind of like a
teeter-totter if you've ever done on the
playground where you try to balance like
the left and right sides you're trying
to keep it equal try to keep it even
right so we're going to do the same
thing to both sides you can see that
these cancel cancel out because that's
just going to be zero so we're left with
x
equals and now we just have to figure
out what 7.1 minus 2.5 is
well let's see one minus 5 we can't do
that so let's borrow from the seven
that's six so this becomes like an 11 11
minus 5 is 6 and 6 minus two is a four
so now we can see that X is equal to
4.6 so with these problems I try to
include some fractions some decimals
some positive and negative numbers to
kind of help you practice those skills
as well and then you can see the last
step here is to solve for one of the
variable in this case we just had one X
so we're done so x equals 4.6 now with
equations the nice thing about algebra
is you can check your work if you take
the 4.6 you put it back in for X 4.6
plus 2.5 yes it equals the original
number which was 7.1 so you can always
check your your work okay let's go to
example number two now so here we have
two-thirds is equal to x minus one half
again our goal is always to find out
what the variable is that's like our
mystery number our unknown quantity
so again I'm following these three easy
steps the first step is to just simplify
the left and the right sides so in this
case can we simplify the left side not
really it's just a number can we
simplify the right side not really
because we have a variable and a number
we really can't combine those together
they're unlike terms so step number two
is to get the variables and the numbers
on opposite sides of the equal sign so
in this case because the variable X is
on the right side of the equation where
we'll just draw a line to divide the two
sides we need to get the numbers on the
opposite side so instead of subtracting
one half I'm going to do the opposite
I'm going to add one-half whatever I do
to the right I want to do to the left
to keep this equation balanced right
negative one half plus one half is zero
this becomes X and then what's
two-thirds plus one-half well we know
when we work with fractions and we're
adding or subtracting we have to have
common denominators it looks like the
common denominator here is going to be 6
and sometimes what you might want to do
when you're working through these steps
here if you have to do some calculations
it doesn't hurt to like do some of the
work on the side and then bring it back
into the equation but it's helpful to
keep things lined up your equal signs
lined up and to be very neat and
organized so we'll go over here to the
side we'll say two-thirds plus one half
looks like they have a common
denominator of six I just have to
multiply this fraction by two over two
and this fraction by three over three
this way we get 3 6
plus 4 6 which is going to be equal to 7
6 which is 1 and 1 6 as a mixed number
and then our last step is always to
solve for just one of the variable in
this case we just have one X by itself
so we're done x equals 1 and 1 6. again
if you want to check your work put that
one and one six back in for X subtract a
half and verify that it equals
two-thirds if it does you know you got
it right if it doesn't you know you're
gonna have to see where you made your
mistake okay let's go ahead and take a
look at example number three now these
are just the one step equations we're
going to get into some more challenging
ones but working with the one step here
we've got three-fifths x equals 15. now
let's go through the steps we want to
simplify the left and right sides well
with these one step equations usually
there's not much to do as far as the
simplifying you can't can do anything on
the right here there's nothing we can do
on the left
so step number two we want to get the
variables and the numbers on opposite
sides well it looks like we've already
got our variables see this is
three-fifths X that's on the left we've
got our number here 15 that's on the
right so we're really down to step
number three which is to solve for just
one of the variable here we have
three-fifths X we just want One X
so how do we get rid of this
three-fifths well
when the two quantities are right next
to each other side by side like that
that means they're multiplied together
so the opposite of multiplying by
three-fifths would be to divide both
sides by three-fifths again remember
whatever you do to the left side you
want to do to the right side
to keep the equation balanced now
anything divided by itself is one so we
have One X
and then remember when you divide it's
like multiplying by the reciprocal so
it's going to be 15
times the reciprocal of three-fifths
which is five-thirds now remember any
whole number can be written as a
fraction by putting it over one
and then we can multiply across here
this is going to give us actually let's
just do it right here so this is going
to be 75 over 3.
which is equal to 25.
and again notice I like to keep the
equal signs lined up to separate the
left and right sides I like to do just
one step per line and then you know
sometimes what I'll even do is draw like
a little line in between each of these
steps and then just keep everything
organized now again if you want to check
your work if you put 2 25 back in
three-fifths so 25 is 15 it checks out
okay let's look at the last one step
type of equation number four and again
let's follow follow the steps here we've
got simplify the left and right sides so
can we simplify what's here on the left
not really there's not much we can do
here it can be simplify what's on the
right no not really so step number two
get the variables and the numbers on
opposite sides well you can see we have
the variables here on the left we can
see we have the numbers on the right so
that's step two and then the last step
you always want to solve for just a one
other variable Just One X
but our question is how can we get rid
of this negative 0.2
well you see how this is X is divided by
negative 0.2 and we know that Division
and multiplication are opposites of each
other just like adding and subtracting
our opposites so instead of dividing by
negative 0.2 let's multiply
both sides by negative 0.2 that way
these undo one another so we're just
left with X but if I multiply the left
side by negative 0.2 we need to multiply
the right side by negative 0.2 now
a negative times a negative is a
positive so let's just write a plus sign
or positive there and then when we
multiply 2 times 6 is 12
times 2 is 4 plus 1 is 5 and then we've
moved the decimal place once twice so
I'm going to move it once twice so you
can see X is coming out to positive
0.52
and you got it now again if you want to
check your work you take that 0.52 and
you put it back in 0.52 divided by
negative 0.2
gives you negative 2.6 so you can verify
let's take a look at the two-step
equations next okay for number five now
we have two x minus three equals eleven
a two-step equation but I always like to
think of these three steps just to keep
it real simple so first up can we
simplify the left side and can we
simplify the right side meaning can we
combine like terms or condense this in
any fashion well in this case we really
can't this is a variable this is a
number we can't combine them and this is
just a number here we can't simplify
that right side so step number two we
want to get the variables and the
numbers on opposite sides of this equal
sign so here I can see that I have the
variables on the left side so that means
I want to get the numbers on the right
side but to get the numbers on the right
side that's like saying I have to get
rid of them on the left how do we get
rid of something we do the opposite so
instead of subtracting 3 I'm going to
add 3 to both sides
and then we just add these two lines
together so 11 plus 3 is 14. carry our
equal sign down negative 3 plus 3 is 0
and 2x okay now we're down to step
number three which is to solve for just
one of the variable here you can see we
have 2X and again notice the 2 and the X
are side by side next to each other that
means they're multiplied together so the
opposite of multiplying by 2 is to
divide by two
whatever we do to the left you want to
do to the right
2 divided by 2 is 1 so we get 1 x is
equal to 14 divided by 2 which is 7.
and you got it now if you want to check
your work you go back to the original 2
times 7 is 14 minus 3 equals eleven so
it makes the equation true so we know
we've got the correct answer
okay let's take a look at number six now
same idea we want to simplify the left
and right sides if possible so in this
case we really can't combine the one
half X and the two because that's a
variable that's a number they're unlike
terms negative four that's just a number
we can't simplify that with anything on
the left side here
so step number two how do we get the
variables and the numbers on opposite
sides well we can see here that we have
the variables on the right see the
axonknown is on the right which means we
want to get the numbers on the left to
get the numbers on the left that's like
saying we have to get rid of them on the
right by doing the opposite instead of
adding 2 we're going to subtract 2 from
both sides
2 minus 2 is 0.
bring our equal sign down one half X
and then negative 4 minus 2 is negative
6. so if you need to review your
positive and negative numbers you can
check out some of my videos on mastering
negative numbers
okay so now we're down to step number
three which is to solve for just one of
the variable we've got one half times x
but we just want One X so what's the
opposite of multiplying by a half
dividing by a half right now sometimes
when I have fractions instead of
dividing what I'll do is I'll just
multiply by the reciprocal so I'll
multiply by two over one
this way
you can see these cancel and that just
gives us the variable X by itself if we
multiply by 2 on the right we want to
multiply by 2 on the left and 2 times
negative 6 is negative 12.
and that's our final answer we solve for
just one of the variable now again if
you want to check your work you put it
back in one half times negative 12 is
negative 6 negative 6 plus 2 is negative
four it checks out let's talk about when
you have variables on both sides of the
equation the left and the right let's do
that next number seven now we've got
variables on the left variables on the
right so a little bit more challenging
but we're still going to follow these
three easy steps so first step can we
simplify the left side and can we
simplify the right side well it looks
like we have a variable and a number we
can't combine those on the right side
variable number we can't combine those
so step one there's nothing we can
really do but step two now we're going
to get the variables and numbers on
opposite sides of the equation now it
doesn't matter whether you get the
variables on the left and the numbers on
the right or vice versa it's up to you
sometimes one way might seem a little
bit easier than another but you're going
to get the same answer in the end so in
this case I'm just going to get the
variables on the left side to get the
variables on the left side that means I
have to get rid of them on the right
side how do you get rid of something by
doing the opposite this is like a
positive 3x which is a plus like like
addition okay plus 3x we're gonna do the
opposite we're going to subtract 3x If I
subtract 3x from the right side I have
to subtract 3x from the left side
so now 7x minus 3x is 4X I'm going to
bring down the minus 2. keep our equal
signs lined up 3x minus 3x is 0. I'm
going to bring down the 10. okay now
we've got the variables on the left we
want to get the numbers on the right how
do we get the numbers on the right we
have to get rid of them on the left by
doing the opposite instead of
subtracting 2 we're going to add to
and we want to do it to both sides to
keep it balanced negative 2 plus 2 is 0.
let's bring down the 4X
keep our equal signs lined up 10 plus 2
is 12. so now you can see we've
accomplished getting the variables and
the numbers on opposite sides
we want to solve for just one of the
variable for our last step we've got 4X
we just want 1X you can see they're next
to each other that means that they're
multiplied together so instead of
multiplying by 4 let's divide both sides
by four
4 divided by 4 is 1 so we get X is equal
to 12 divided by 4 which is 3 and you
got it now if you want to check your
work you take the 3 you put it back in
for this X and this X and you simplify
make sure the left and the right sides
they match
for number eight another equation where
we have variables and numbers
on both sides so we're going to go
through the three steps simplify the
left side and the right side if possible
so here on the left side I can see that
I've got a positive 3 and a positive 8 I
can add those together so 3 plus 8 is
going to give us
11 or positive 11 or plus 11. and here
we really can't combine anything because
we just have a variable and a number and
they're just added together they're
unlike terms so that's step number one
step number two get the variables and
the numbers on opposite sides it doesn't
matter which side you pick and this
problem we got the variables on the left
so how about on this problem we get the
variables on the right just for variety
so so if I want to get the variables on
the right I have to get rid of them on
the left by doing the opposite so I'm
going to add 4X
to both sides
negative 4X plus 4X is zero I'm going to
bring down the 11 negative 6X plus 4X is
negative 2x I'm going to bring down the
10. okay now we have the variables on
the right which means we want to get the
numbers on the left how do we get the
numbers on the left we have to get rid
of them on the right by doing the
opposite I'm going to subtract 10 from
both sides that gives us 0 here
this is negative 2X
and 11 minus 10 is 1. last step we want
to solve for just one of the variable we
have a negative 2x we just want 1X
what's the opposite of multiplying by
negative 2. dividing by negative 2
and so now you can see this is 1x equals
negative one-half
and that's our final answer we solve for
one of the variable now you can put this
back in for X wherever you see X and
simplify the left side and right side
make sure that they match
and verify now you might be saying right
here I'm thinking out loud negative 2x
some students might think well isn't
this subtracting 2 shouldn't I be adding
2 but remember when they're right next
to each other like that it's understood
to be multiplication so instead of
multiplying we're going to divide let's
take a look at the multi-step equations
now for number nine we've got
this equation which looks a little bit
more complicated than what we've been
working with so let's follow the three
steps first starting with simplifying
the left side as much as you can and the
right side as much as you can
so here you can see that we have this
five on the outside of the parentheses
and when you have that five right next
to the parentheses like that what we do
is the distributive property which means
that you're multiplying the 5 into the
parentheses so 5 times x is 5X 5 times
negative 3 is negative 15 and then we
have this minus 2 here
same thing on the right side that 2 is
right next to the parentheses we're
going to multiply or distribute into the
parentheses 2 times x is 2x 2 times 1 is
positive 2 and then now we're still on
step one
we're still in the process of
simplifying the left side and the right
side as much as we can and I can see
that we can combine the negative 15 and
the negative 2 that's going to give us
negative 17 and here we can combine the
two minus 4 which is just negative 2.
so sometimes even though it's three easy
steps you might spend a couple of lines
you know or a couple of you know
processes to complete that first step
here okay so step number two now we want
to get the variables and the numbers on
opposite sides now sometimes students
like to set it up in such a way that
they don't have any negative variables
like that and so they might say well I'm
going to try to get the variables here
because I can see that's going to work
out to a positive number but it really
doesn't matter as long as you get the
numbers on one side variables on the
opposite side so I'm going to get the
variables on the left by getting rid of
them on the right
so I'm going to subtract 2x from both
sides I like to draw a line like that
and I think about just kind of adding
straight down so 5x plus negative 2x is
equal to 3x
bring down the negative 17.
2x minus 2x is 0. bring down the
negative 2. okay we've got our variables
on the left we want to get our numbers
on the right how do we get them on the
right we have to get rid of them on the
left by doing the opposite instead of
minusing 17 we're going to add 17.
that cancels out we're left with just 3x
and negative 2 plus 17 is 15. now we've
completed our getting the variables on
the left numbers on the right we're on
step three solving for just one of the
variable here we have 3x we just want 1X
instead of multiplying by 3 Let's divide
both sides by 3.
3 divided by 3 is 1 and you can see
we're getting x equals 15 divided by 3
which is 5 and you got it now again if
you want to take some time and go back
and put 5 in here five in here wherever
you see X simplify both sides make sure
that the left side and the right sides
match and verify you got the right
answer
okay for number 10 same idea
got a lot going on here but if we follow
these three steps we're going to get to
what x equals now sometimes students say
well couldn't I just maybe try plugging
in some numbers like one or two and see
if it matches see that would take a long
time you might be able to do that in
like the one step equations and maybe
even the two-step equations but it's
hard to guess what x is on these
multi-step so that's why we like to
follow this process
so let's simplify the left side as much
as we can we're going to distribute the
one-half into the parentheses that's
going to give us one half times 6X which
is 3x one half times negative 12 is
negative 6. over here we've got 2x plus
1X is 3x and I'm going to bring down the
minus 4. now we want to get variables
and numbers on opposite sides so that's
step number two so I'm going to get the
variables on the left so I'm going to
subtract them on the right so minus 3x
minus 3x
okay that cancels that cancels look what
we're left with negative 6 is equal to
negative 4 which doesn't really make any
sense right how could negative 6 equal
negative four there are two different
numbers so what that tells you when the
variable cancels out like that and
you're left with something that's uh
doesn't make any sense I call it a
nonsensical answer that tells you that
there's actually no solution
to this equation meaning no matter what
you put in for X the left side and the
right side will never match so this is
kind of like a special case but is
important to recognize let's take a look
at two more multi-step examples
if you've made it this far in the video
you probably like the way that I explain
things and if you're learning about
algebra and you want to go deeper with
me I've got an algebra 1 course for sale
and an Algebra 2 college algebra video
course for sale and I've got links in
the description below so check out those
video courses they each consist of like
about 85 and the other one has 87
lessons and I take you step by step you
know each lesson building on the
previous lesson we go through the
concepts we go through example problems
I give you some problems you can
practice on your own and we go through
those as well so the courses are are
very detailed and if you like the way I
explain things check those out but for
number 11 let's continue on with this I
try to make each problem a little bit
different than the the previous problems
because I want you to kind of learn as
much as you can as quickly as you can
but I also have to try to include the
different types so you can kind of see
what things that you're going to
encounter so let's look at 11 and 12 and
then that will wrap up this a lesson but
here we've got 4X and negative 1X that
adds up to 3x and I'm going to bring
down that minus 5. over here on the
right side we're going to do that
distributive property again that's 3x
plus 6 bring down the minus 11.
now we're still on the first step of
simplifying the left side of the right
side I can see that I can combine the 6
and the negative 11.
that's going to be negative 5.
and here we've got 3x minus 5. now you
might notice at this step you know let's
say Mario I can see that the left side
and the right side are equal what does
that mean well they call that an
identity like the left side is identical
to the right side and when you have that
it tells you that there's going to be
infinitely many solutions because
whatever you put in for X the left side
and the right side are going to be the
same but say you don't notice that and
you say well I'm going to subtract 3x
for both sides of the equation
and then you end up with something like
negative 5 equals negative 5. you notice
your variable is gone
but what you're left with is exactly the
same so that's another way to recognize
that it's an identity or you could say
infinitely many solutions or all real
numbers
okay in the last example number 12 if
you're getting the hang of this see if
you can pause the video
and try this one on your own this one
I'm going to distribute first so
negative 14x Plus 7.
we're still on the first step we're
going to combine like terms negative 14x
plus 1X is negative 13x
well 7.
okay now here what I'm going to do I'm
going to get the variables on the right
by getting rid of them on the left so
I'm going to do the opposite I'm going
to add 13x to both sides
so that cancels we've got 7 is equal to
21x minus 2 got the variables on the
right which means we want to get the
numbers on the left so we'll do the
opposite we're going to add 2 to both
sides
so these cancel we get 21x is equal to 9
and we want to just solve for one of the
variables so we're going to divide both
sides by 21.
and with fractions you always want to
reduce to lowest terms I can see that 3
goes into both of these 3 goes into 9 3
times 3 goes into 21 7 times so our
answer is x equals 3 7. again you can
plug it back in and verify that the left
side and the right side match and this
is a good answer so if you like this
video but you want some more practice
learning about how to solve one variable
equations whether it's one step two-step
multi-step variables on both sides
follow me over to that previous video I
did right there to get some more
practice I'll see over in that video